[Music]
la
all right what's going on everyone
welcome to today's MLB on TBS conference
call and webcast over the next hour or
so I'm joined by my castmates the Hall
of Famer Pedro Martinez Gary Sheffield
and our newbie our rookie on set this
year for the NL our buddy Dusty Baker
our Skipper keeping us all in line we'll
spend the next hour getting you ready
for all of our coverage of course
beginning tonight 7:30 eastern time
getting you ready for Cubs Pirates so
dusty I'll start with you what are you
looking forward to most from tonight's
game between two great aces of this game
uh actually I'm looking for a lot of
excitement in in Pittsburgh because I've
been there just a couple years ago and
the crowd's going to be unbelievable uh
I'm telling you it's going to be loud
it's going to be obnoxious and those
people are ready to go to the next level
Pedro two big starters big spots how
much do you love the mentality of each
of these guys going into this game no
problem with either one both of look
great said the right things they seem to
be ready I'm looking forward to the
match up but I'm a little sad you're sad
yeah because I would like to see both
teams go to the playoffs yes the wild
the Wild Card 97 win against the 98 win
uh I'm not sure how many runs we're
going to see total tonight but take us
through the approach Chef you're a
hitter facing an arietta haven't had
success on the other side Cubbies
haven't had any success this year really
against Cole how do you approach it as a
hitter tonight attack attack attack you
go go in the playoffs taking pitches and
getting behind on these guys it's going
to be a long night you got to go in
there ready to hit first pitch fastball
and if they throw anything else if it
flattens out over the plate you hack on
that too you don't want to get deep in
count on these guys especially in the
playoff like Houston did last night yes
you got to attack always attack and uh
kyel obviously pretty good last night
too boys Yankees going home we've got a
lot to get to fan questions as well
let's start how about not going local
going Long Island for me to Neil besta
Newsday who's got the first question for
us guys go ahead
Neil pitching what do you think of this
Mets Dodgers series and how that might
play out in terms of you know the great
arms on both sides Pedro Mets and
Dodgers and the arms on both sides I
think it's going to be exciting uh I I
I'll tell you what I I I believe Clayton
Kershaw is due to have a big postseason
uh you know the Mets coming over away
from from from New York and playing in
in in La where where um I think the
Dodgers play a lot more comfortable than
than on the road I think it's going to
be exciting to see I would love to see
kersha against Harvey but but the grum
is not an easy task as well so it's
going to be really exciting to see how
this young group of pitchers evolve
around the playoffs and you know facing
the big horses in grank and and kersha
uh if they pull out a win it's going to
be great P I think that that the Mets
have to get into the middle of the uh of
the Dodgers Bullpen and if they get in
the middle of bull pin and if those guys
don't go deep in the game you know
grinkie and Kershaw you know I think
Advantage Mets and you mentioned the
home field Chef how about the Shadows
Dodgers get the first two games I I
think Met fans should be if they're
watching this a little bit afraid giving
those two games away and getting on the
road as a hitter I mean that's pretty
tough you're going to go face Kershaw
and grank well yeah I mean that's why in
the playoffs especially in is the same
mindset you have when you you're hitting
in Shadows hit the first fast ball you
see and get from up there I mean because
the the longer you you're at back goes
and you're behind it just make it that
much tougher because you're thinking
about is he going to throw me a breaking
ball is he going to throw me that nasty
slider or he's going to throw heat so
you got always going to be behind and
see especially that time of the night I
mean you know chef and I both played
there right and I'm all our games I
hated playing those games at Twilight I
mean it was tough
because you can't pick the ball up K is
very deceiving there's going to be a lot
of prayer from hitters I think hoping
for the bloop and a blast let's stay La
let's blast out there from the LA Daily
News getting a chance to talk with Tom
hoffarth go ahead thanks for the
question no sure uh again the bullpen
has been the Dodgers concern all year
how can they get around that issue um
and make it something that's a plus for
them rather than a negative did the Mets
have uh their eyes set on getting to
dodg your Bullpen as fast as possible
it's good question last year guys and
Pedro I'll start with you last year we
saw the Kershaw decision with Matt
Carpenter really what it came down to
was there was no bridge that term we
looked to how you getting to kley Jansen
do you feel any better about this group
and how do as the question is asked how
do you try and minimize maybe a little
bit of a weakness there in that six
seventh eth inning well they made some
improvement from last year to this year
and I've seen some guys come up and do a
little bit more of a decent job for the
Dodgers but I I still believe dy I don't
know how you feel about it I I think
they they have to pull one of those
starters kind of you know young or
whatever that that's used to pitching in
in in those middle Innings and and
getting righties and lefties out to try
to bridge to to get to Jensen I think if
they can pull one of those young
starters or or you know uh someone that
has had the experience of pitching in
the middle of situations they can
probably build the Gap to get to well
this is when A Star is Born yeah and and
a lot of times you I mean you don't
really know that's right I mean that
happened to us when I was in LA you know
you know Bobby Welch you know was was in
that situation you know he was a starter
and all of a sudden now you know he's in
the bullpen and you know some guys are
looking their chops this is what you
just said they're going to take that
oners of this is my shot and they going
to go out there and show the manager and
their team what they're capable of and
the world and what what they're capable
in this situation this is time
here's the best news for the Dodgers the
Mets have the exact same problem and the
way that they've pitched trying to get
to Familia big issues there as well
let's go la as well to LA Times Bill
shaken bill go ahead you're up
next thank you I wanted to ask Pedro
specifically about all the heat that the
Mets young pitchers throw there three
starters going to come all 95 97 how
hard is that going to be especially for
veteran hitters that La has to catch up
with well they're on it's going to be a
long night because I I know kersha and
greny uh are going to put up a fight and
and they're proven that they're going to
keep you in the game so I believe that
if if the grum and and and cergar are
able to execute it's going to it's going
to be a task for both teams now it's
going to go probably to fundamentals who
plays the small ball you know uh better
and and and and you have to go a vanage
experience when it comes to that but the
are not too far behind they have guys
like Juan Ube who was you know in La for
a long time they have guys like sesp and
those guys that know too ker veteran
professional hitter David Wright those
are guys that know how to play the game
and uh I I think it's going to be pretty
exciting I I hope it is the series that
we all expect I hope I hope the series
goes down to pitching and fundamentals
in instead of having you know slug Fest
and and and guys go sou I think SL you
ain't going to see no slug Fest but I
would love to see one yeah hey but I
tell you you know in series like this
the teams that gets the most two out uh
base hits yes RBI those are the teams
that usually win yeah there a scrappy
runs one thing very underrated when
you've got two two sides both who can
pitch defense oh yeah don't make the
error that puts somebody in scoring
position and all of a sudden then you
can manufacture run that I love defense
hey well you have to you need some you
can't catch man you get on the field
when we when we talk about fundamentals
that's attack
we we go back out to our field in Maria
gado from the Star Ledger is next hi
Maria go
ahead he um so I was just wondering
about um what you guys thought of the
the wildart game between the Yankees and
in the Astros last night would you think
of K's performance and were you do you
think that Yankees kind of underachieved
or overachieved this year just based on
on how they ended their season let's go
to the Yankee first chef what's he say
did the Yankees underachieve based on
the way that they ended their season in
the one playoff game and going home last
night not doing much oh I mean when the
Yankees NE if they don't win the penet
they underachieve I mean they got a high
payroll they got all these Superstars
you bringing elberry and pay this guy
$20 million and he don't even start for
you I mean that's a big disappointment
to me that's the first thing I noticed
and I looked at on their team this is
the new guy you paid him a lot of money
and he sitting on the bench there's a
problem there Pedro let's go kikel this
is a guy we questioned he had that one
bad start on the road in Texas remember
gave up the nine runs since then
brilliant brilliant in the last weekend
to get them into the playoffs and he was
terrific again yesterday what you see
you know what happened in Texas is that
Texas Came Out Swinging the Yankees did
not the Yankees allowed him to execute
his plan and and uh he used Cooper the
the home played umpire as good as I've
ever seen never gave the Yankees
something come to swing at never gave
the Yankees something in the
same area of the strike zone never gave
the Yankees a pattern and and and when
believe me he surprised me too because
he reacted like a guy that has been
around forever as far as executing those
corners and hitting those corners and
off the corners a little bit uh and
repeating it and repeating it until
Cooper just went high and cold but Pedro
I mean if you a Major League hitter you
got to be able to hit the ball a half an
inch off the plate and a half an inch
inside you got to be able to handle both
sides of the plate I mean more they
can't maybe more than that but I mean
you me to tell me that you can't even
Square this guy up but you got to have a
plan look like the Yanke the Yanke was
flat this look like to me you can't get
both sides of the plate I mean early in
the count I'm looking outside I'm
looking inside but it looked like they
really didn't have a plan look like they
were just trying to make him pitch you
know like the on three days rest and you
know like they were going to get his
pitch count up it was strike one big
time but what happened what happened was
they they gave him pitches early the
game so he he started getting that that
breaking ball getting the feel for that
breaking ball and by the time they
realized it he was he was pinpointing
away elevating good the the breaking
ball got good SL down and the change up
was nasty yeah I mean as a hitter it
changes your mindset as a hitter when
they're getting calls it does it does so
now you get in swing mode now but I can
see the frustration on the Yankees faces
when when the ball was up down a little
bit in or out and they're looking like
this was too late strike two St that's
the job of a picture disrupt your timing
and confuse you and that's exactly what
it did like conf I love that was a piece
of art I I enjoy that you tell who's the
picture can you tell who's the pitcher
on this set and the Dusty's Point by the
way that back door that slider back foot
against righties was nasty yesterday
let's go right out to the New York Post
to Ken David off hey Kenny how are
you good guys uh Pedro you you talked
about the uh the elite starting pitchers
and as as one yourself considering how
many guys don't make it to this level
guys with potential what would you say
is the is the most important quality
that that a guy needs to reach sort that
sort of height well I think when if
you're a pitcher and you have what it
takes as far as you know fast ball a
repertoire I I I would say all you have
to do is command the the strike zone if
you command either side of the plate you
have a shot and and dust you you manage
and you know that when you ask for for
for a pitch away and you have a guy 90
plus he he should get you out if he hits
either side of the plate and that's
that's what you need and you can stack
your defense if he's throwing a the ball
where he wants where you want to exactly
but that's a prime example of you look
at the Atlanta bravs which SM glav and
the Maddox when I played right field
there I knew where the ball was coming
Andrew knew where it was coming Chipper
Jones knew where it was coming you guys
would take off running before the pitch
exactly I mean I was I would literally
sit behind SEC the second basem and
Andrew would come over to me and he has
the Gap and chipper plays deep and so in
that Gap so they knew we knew you Wen
going to pull him to the left field line
and every ball was hit to us with ease
that's and that's a prime example you
set up your your defense imagine if you
have that was just a fast ball if you
have somehow any kind of breaking ball
or change up or change up you you now
you become someone reliable and that
that's what they need they need to hit
location they they need to be able to
hit in and out you think about Tanaka
the command wasn't that way for him
yesterday and it was the opposite you
know we talked in our in our last show
on Sunday about fear right you could
tell he had it in his own eyes Dusty
we're watching the game we watching the
game last night he wasn't right so a
hitter's going to notice that too well
all you had to do is look at his pitch
selection right some of those at bats
all he had to do is go right at the
hitters he was snatching balls over like
Pedro said he may be injured might
because he was snatching some balls and
missing locations back you know when I
saw him walk you know Chris Carter a
couple times not even close not even
close he didn't want no part of him no
part of him I said Whoa man not going to
throw well but it's not it's not because
he couldn't I mean it's not because he
didn't want to he couldn't and that
that's a a sign that tells me I was hurt
for many years and and and and I and I
got hurt during the season and I pitch
sometimes through some injuries yeah and
the the first thing you lose is your is
your command to locate your your pitches
when you're healthy even yeah oh yeah
you you don't commit to pitches as the
way you want you don't you don't you
don't go you know full gas to the to the
area that you want to you want to go to
like let's you don't commit to inside
that much you don't want to completely
go right so when you limit yourself what
you do is you your mechanics have to
adjust to your limit and sometimes when
you have your mechanics and your normal
routine and you try to just limit your
pitch it it's going to take off
somewhere else and that's what happened
he he's he didn't feel right so he
limited pitches he pulled the fast ball
and hung the breaking balls that's
exactly what would happen to someone
that's hurting somewhere and and yeah at
the time he hung that breaking ball to
to Gomez Gomez was trying to hit a
ground ball to second to move the run
over that's what he said unbelievable
but that's a prime example of me facing
a guy if I see he's having problems with
his command if he missed by that much oh
man and I don't even attempt that to
pitch I'm going to set him up just way I
want then it's lunch time it's lunch
time you got to be ready to swing you
got to be ready to swing I mean cuz it's
it's like these guys didn't 3-1 pitches
we saw yeah cookies I'm like what do you
oh no good let I mean I don't know what
to tell him let's let's tell you this
let's go to Jerry Fry Dallas Morning
News hey Jarry how are
you good how are you hey I have an
American League question for Pedro if I
could please sure uh Pedro Adrien Beltre
this year became the all-time leader in
games played by players from the
Dominican Republic
first join you you expect to see him
join you in Cooperstown someday first
botot without a doubt uh if you watch
Beltre developing you know Third Base
he's got to be in the top five third
basem all time and and I and you know
what I don't want him to finish it I
want him to put up some more numbers I
but I I believe uh Adrian berre is
already a a first ballot Hall of Fame
and um even though his arrival to
Cooperstown is going to be delayed a
little bit I don't mind it but he is for
sure to me uh a first ballot Hall of
Famer and not only that he's carrying
that Texas team I'm so happy for him and
and for the Texas Ranger I'm also happy
for Prince Fielder coming off that
injury oh my God I'm so happy for and
I'm happy for S Su and I like I like the
momentum they have too I I love that
team and I love Adrian and I hope he
joins me in Cooperstown but not yet keep
putting numbers some more clutch hits
still in that bat we saw that last day
of the Season let's go to mlb.com my old
digs with Jerry tahil go ahead
joh John tahil sorry about that John go
right
ahead do we have
John all right let's go to Jeff passin
from Yahoo hey Jeff go
ahead on guys thanks for uh having me
here uh you know there's been so much
that's been said about Unwritten rules
recently and I'd like to get the
perspective Ive from former players why
Unwritten rules are so important to
baseball players uh and why when there's
so many seeming hypocrisies among them
uh generation after generation still
sticks with them
anyway well I mean I I know I know about
Unwritten rules and I think is to keep
you in your place pretty much it's about
respecting the game to a degree for that
that's more designed for the young
players you know once you get older you
learn how to play the game and play
right it's more for the young players to
say okay you got to serve your time and
then you can have your freedom to do
what you do but it's up to the older
players to teach them yes to pass it on
yes you know because I was always told
hey man it's not yours to possess it's
yours to pass on right and it was passed
on to us it passed on to you guys and
there are certain things in the game
that you have to you have to respect the
game and also respect the opposition uh
uh you know at the same time and you you
know what to expect after while
absolutely and uh you know there are
certain things that uh uh everybody
talks about the unwritten rules but
nobody everybody's looking for this book
you know there is the code of baseball
ethics yeah I mean it's passed on from
generation to generation I'm hoping that
it continues I I I'll tell you what John
I don't know if you do that but but we
all did no of course we once had a
little black book where you keep your
secret things well the black the black
book of baseball is is the own written
rules I I believe that as players we
keep our secrets we keep our rules we
keep rules between players that there
are not discussed out there with with
the public those those things happen in
the clubhouse those those every team has
a different set of rules and they go by
it and and the old it's like tradition
it's like a family tradition you bring
it you pass it on and on and on to the
next Generations and that's what
happened in baseball we all have
Unwritten rules but most of them out of
the I pretty much the black book of The
Players but Pedro when I first got to
the Atlanta Braves I walked in the
clubhouse 1968 and on up there over the
over the training room door it says what
goes on in here stays in here that's
right exactly and I didn't know what
what the heck that meant but I soon
found out yeah me they didn't have
Twitter yeah that's yeah I mean but yeah
I mean every team have this different
rules as well yeah and so you got to
adjust to what works in that City I was
let me just throw this real quick on the
back into that because I'm curious It's
a good question from Jeff is when you've
got the policing because I deal with
this when we talk to people all the time
umpires have warnings they're all
handled differently managers have the
way they handle it some you hit one I
hit one we've seen it let's not name
names you hit one of mine I hit four
right are the rules all the same are we
all on the same page well basically I
think I think most of the rules are the
same you know the the thing about it
is you know when you come into this game
when you come into this game and the
veterans take you under their ring there
are certain things that that they tell
you to do and don't do and some things
to never do and some other things to
expect and see I think a lot of guys
don't know kind of what to expect I was
telling you a story last night when when
when somebody threw at me and my best
friend Gary Matthews was on the Cubs and
Terry forer asked me hey were they
throwing at you I says yep and he said
and he says you want me to drill the
next guy I said yep and he goes who is
it I said Gary Matthews and I says you
got to get him and that's my best friend
but I said look I'll play right behind
his second base I mean the short stop
and I'll try to get there as quickly as
I can cuz this guy can really fight and
that's the thing I'm talking about and
we hit him and and he looked at me I
looked at him went the first boom yeah
but see that's the part of I want the
unwritten rule to be when I charge
nobody can get involved oh I love that
and that's what thir no Third Man in if
you bad enough to hit me then deal with
the consequence
either one of us going to deal with them
I think we we do it like that it change
I wouldn't do you like that I see I I I
hated asking I I I asked once and that
person I asked said I I don't know just
just make a statement said that would be
the last time I asked as soon as I saw a
teammate that got hit and that's why
sometimes you know those those are rules
that I wanted to pass along sure you
don't have to do a big deal you don't
have to go ask your teammate if your if
your teammate felt discomfort about the
fact that he got hit or gave you some
kind of gesture one look whatever there
are times where where you know it's not
intentional right right and and yeah it
hurts and we but we know when not inal
there's no intention now when a teammate
like you you get hit and and you just
have that discomfort you just didn't
feel right about it I'll just remain the
same way I used to be that's right cuz
you cuz you paying attention yeah pay
ATT you have to you have to and then
I'll just go do my thing nobody knows
anything my men walked around and nobody
anything all of a sudden one of yours is
walking down he needs to walk but it
might be it might be three months from
now yeah it could also be or the next
outing against you yeah yeah it could be
some sometimes you can't handle things
right then and there correct but I did
not sometimes it's more important to win
that game of course you know sometimes
that game you know sometimes it's more
important to win that game that gets
forgot that got that's got to be put on
the back burner let's go to Scott Miller
from Bleach report hey Scott how are
you hey guys how's everybody um question
Matt
Harvey uh about a month or so ago drops
the Innings pitched limit and that blows
up in New York and then the other day
when he when he shows up late to the
workout I I'm wondering a couple things
Dusty from a manager's perspective uh
how quick do you have to handle that
when it looks you know you wonder if
Harvey is kind of separating himself
from the team and and then D after Dusty
chef and Pedro uh does it concern you
that his relationship with his teammates
could eventually be in jeopardy with
moves like this hey those are very good
questions uh I think as a manager you
got to handle it right away and uh you
have to handle immediately um I I think
it has to be known uh uh from the get-go
that my number one rle rule was don't be
late to work and uh and if you're going
to be late then you call me but just
don't be late more than a couple times
in a short period of time and and to me
you have to handle it because you have
to handle it now while he's young cuz
what's going to happen later on and also
also you got these other teammates
looking at you to see how you're going
to handle it and in order to keep
respect with the other teammates I think
that's very very important uh you know
how you handle it well I mean I I said
they should have been this a long time
ago I mean these start these things
starting to pile up now and now you
seeing him starting to get away with
some things that shouldn't happen in a
young player he's doing veteran moves if
if anybody can get away with it but
veterans don't even do this right and if
they want the guys to follow them as
veterans these are the things you can't
do all of those pictures I'm sure look
up to Matt Harvey I mean he's the
dominant guy there and he's pulling
these acts right now that's an
organization problem
I I I I I have to agree I I I think U
they should handle it and and and and
and immediately and realize as well
because I love what Terry Collins did
the other day yeah I'm mad yeah I'm
upset about that yeah I'm saying he's
gonna do this and he's gonna do that
it's about time he got pissed right and
now now I think Harvey is in an age and
time in baseball where you can still
hold the leash mhm hold him hey hey I
know you're a big horse you have a lot
of blood you want to run your your race
but no I'm I'm the YY right here and I'm
hold you this is our race we wait for
the for for the rest of the horses and
and you still have plenty of time to
hold the leash on Harvey management and
everybody needs to get together to hold
the leash a little bit get him straight
and and and believe me we also have to
understand everybody messes up one day
absolutely one day
he gets the benefit of a doubt this is
the first time I hear something about
him being late somewhere now I don't
know how how much it happened um in the
clubhouse yeah because we were just
talking about the unwritten rules but I
I think some of those veterans will pull
him aside and say Harvey hey David right
I know is gonna probably get to his face
and say hey are you in or are you out
right now this is the first time he does
it now this is a perfect time after all
that happened right before they got to
the
playoffs to to actually say hey it it
seems like it's escaping your hands what
you're doing now we're going to hold the
leash on you and let us guide you
because you're still young enough to to
be guided by someone like us you know we
all got guided absolutely you know Ian I
mean I was you can't lead if you ain't
never been l oh I'm telling you I was
held by my neck a couple
times show me how you like this and I
like man you don't let me go and go I
let you go then what you know what I
mean it's like big claws on you oh yeah
I'll tell you what though you better
make sure the juice is worth the squeeze
is I like to say because if you don't go
out there and perform in game three oh
boy oh yeah dark night into a dark place
let's go to Paul Banks with the Chicago
Tribune punt next hey Paul how are
you doing
good my question is is for Pedro
Martinez about Jake
aretta um just being a being a pitcher I
know pitching is very psychological and
there's such an intellectual component
to it for Jake to make the comeback that
he did to go from being a guy that you
know had an erra in the fives and the
fours when he was in Baltimore to being
a guy who's got an ER and the ones now
what is how do you undertake that that
intellectual Journey what what is what
do you have to do psychologically to get
there to be as dominant as he
has well
it is a good question but but I'll tell
you what there's a point in your career
where you find that everything clicks
you find the right pitching coach you
right you find the right atmosphere you
find the right manager you feel
comfortable with your teammates you feel
comfortable with the way you're doing
things or you find command of another
pitch yes yeah all those things come
together when when when when everything
when something clicks at one point I
think he went through a period of two
three years where he was figuring out
what he wanted to do now he reached a
point where he felt comfortable and I
saw something that was very important
for him he says I'm not going to think
about mechanics anymore I'm just going
to execute my pitches any way possible
that I can so he found Rhythm he found
you know comfortable mechanics he found
that he didn't have to be like everybody
else and his training went to another
level and and and he's working harder
and harder and and and and because that
he his mental approach is focused he's
he's determined when I saw his interview
yesterday my God I loved it I love the
determination he had in his face his
eyes his presence his look and not only
that jef like you and and and dusty we
all we all went through it yesh we have
that special year that everything goes
our way yes right now betting against
aretta will be a Bad Bet
everywhere I I believe this kid is
having an unbelievable year uh uh you
know we can't expect them to have the
same year every year because this is an
unreal year for him everything is
clicking so for him it's going to
continue to go this way and I hope he's
able to maintain that that that kind of
track that he's taking P Pedro once you
figure it out then you know why can't
you do this I mean I saw Dave Stewart go
from being released from the Phillies to
the to the Oakland A's and he figured it
out one 20 uh uh uh four years in a row
right yeah four years in a row and so
it's like once you figure it out and
you're confidence level and and and you
figure out how you know how I'm going to
train you figure out okay I can throw
this pitch boom boom I can experiment
with this Wang now I got it because you
know the hardest thing is to get it that
is true I mean I I when I first came in
the league I used to be on my way to the
park didn't eat mhm and stop to the
McDonald and grab me a sandwich and and
all of a sudden go in the game and hit a
ground ball and try to Sprint the first
base and I pull a hamstring but when I
changed that and start eating healthier
I started staying healthier right then I
was able to be on the field and then I
could be more consistent and then all of
a sudden it it happens for me and now my
confidence goes through the roof and now
my ability comes out and it just that's
what's happening with this kid and it
happens to a lot of players like Pedro
say things have to take place certain
things happen and it clicks and now your
confidence level go and it happens at
different points and time per player you
know look at Kurt Shilling Kurt
Schilling struggled for I mean for you
know three organizations until he
figured out I mean you some guys get
there and they figure it out early
that's right and some guys it takes time
right some some guys are late bloomers
and edwi andarn is one of those guys uh
Bautista we see them consistently now
hit how many teams gave up on them oh
yeah because because those guys were lay
bloom
and and ARA might be one of those guys
that was a little bit of a late bloomer
and now one other thing that's really
important is Dusty when we get to the
big leags the hype of being there you
know the the the attractive moves of
everywhere in every aspect uh sometimes
could probably distract you a little bit
from what you really should be doing and
and and and you can't blame a young guy
from for for for having fun Puig is one
guy that that embraced baseball and he
thought the world was for for himself
yeah but it would have been different if
yasel P was in a lot of like situations
like my situation King griffy situation
if they would have expected 30 home runs
when he was a rookie it's a different
ball game nobody expected anything but
he's able to go out and play what I'm
saying is a lot of those things distract
you from the things that you should be
doing and for a young player is not
anything rare to have a player being
distracted right ARA maybe didn't Focus
as much in his training because he was
young and powerful and he felt good now
he knows that maintaining that that
training program and maintaining his
focus is going to pay off for the rest
of his career and this kid looks like a
monster that could work out a strong
could last you for many years he's not
common like like he's across his body
and he throws he's nasty overall and not
only that it seems like he knows what
he's doing what he wants to do and he's
going to do it for for a long time let's
go to rock katco next from Masson Sports
go ahead Rock how are
you okay thanks basically I was had a
similar question about Ariana but just
to put maybe another spin on it uh do
you guys feel like G and Pedro that this
was not going to happen in Baltimore
because obviously fans are upset about
that trade uh they got Scott Felman and
Steve cleer back for for ariet and stro
and it certainly looks pretty one-sided
now you guys convinced that he was a
change of scenery type guy they say and
this just wasn't going to happen in
Baltimore uh I don't think it was it was
a problem for him the the scenery I I
think it was just a matter of uh you
know how patient you you wanted to be
with aretta and you know like I said he
was a late bloomer look to me look to me
I I don't know him that well but
watching him pitch he always showed that
he had the talent now uh having the
patience to to f tune and and and find
him mentally to finally get him to feel
comfortable and understanding what he
wanted to do I I I thought every year I
learned not during the season I learned
after the
offseason during the offseason I would
take my videos and I would reflect on
all the things that I did I think aretta
had something happened to him during the
offseason where his workout regimen
changed y uh his mental approach to the
game Chang he said I'm not dealing
anymore with this mechanic things this
concentration I'm Pedro what's missing
in that is that the bottom line is is
the trade happened yeah it woke him up
and said I need to get serious I need to
do something different if he would have
stayed in the same situation I truly
believe he would have stayed been the
same pitcher but see at the same time
you guys in Modern Baseball you have to
like think like the organization thinks
yeah okay he's going to be eligible for
arbitration he's going to be a free
agent this other guy might be a free
agent are we gonna pay him that much
money to wait on a guy that may not get
it right see and that's what happens a
lot of times yeah but I think he would
have stayed in the same picture right
when you when you're in the same
environment and you're getting the same
results then all of a sudden the trade
happens it wakes you up say okay I got
to do something different I got to show
them that they they they it was a it's
going to be a bad loss for them and now
he's out to prove something you can tell
in his attitude and and it certainly
happened and and I just spoke about it I
said sometimes when you when you when
you just find it you find the right
thing that clicks your right pitching
coach your right manager your right
atmosphere the right field I there was
there was another place where I felt
more comfortable except maybe Seattle sh
Stadium everywhere I went I never was
comfortable I felt comfortable on my
field I felt comfortable to pitching but
why everybody got to feel comfortable to
to produce but you know what you know
what you you it's just that your your
mind your your your your your level of
of concentration goes higher when you
feel comfortable when you know that
nothing bothers you that if you go south
you have your pitching coach to guide
you you have someone that it's not it's
not it's not coin maybe maybe pictures
are more sensitive yeah maybe you know
what you know psychologically you know
but you don't know P I'd like to know
who who who scouted him on the Cubs that
saw potential in arietta I saw potential
every time I saw it was always there it
was always there he just needed to fine-
tune what he what he needed well to pull
off the TR you know you know to pull the
trigger on the trade now you're I mean
somebody is is putting something on the
line oh yeah oh yeah you got to you got
to vouch for it that's right but this
guy always had like P say he always had
it it's just the other stuff it's not
coincidence that my best two two seasons
in my career were 99 and 2000 why I had
an extra pitching coach someone reliable
someone I could trust that's right I had
Ramon with me mhhm now if I don't trust
Ramon to tell
or right I I I I'm not going to find a
peaching coach to get comfortable with I
I I found that it clicked for me after
this the first half in 96 I I that was a
time when I felt it clicked for me I I
felt like I belong I felt like I had it
Bobby qu made me made me you know adjust
to some little things right and Bobby qu
was the guy that actually led me to
understanding myself understanding my
body understanding what I was doing and
having an a specific uh uh program that
I wanted to follow as far as training
throwing how I threw my bullpens what I
worked on right then those are things
that clicked and then as I got to Boston
the 998th season I was already a veteran
in 99 I happen to get Ramon by me hey I
was dealing I think pitch is a sensitive
uh I'm just being I would never say such
a thing I'm just saying because you know
well the thing is is that a trade wakes
you up yes because I mean you look at my
stat woke me up and when they traded me
to Sano almost won Triple Crown because
I was told by my manager we don't expect
you to hit just pick up the ball I say
man he must don't know what he talking
to right and I I was out to prove to
everybody that was watching every single
day I'm gonna prove to you get me out of
here and I'm going I'm going to be the
best player in the game two quick things
one it's a misn that the Orioles did not
like Jake arietta which is out there
because I talked to Buck about him five
years ago and there was no question that
they thought it some point it would
click it's just timing and and a trade
sometimes is about timing I can't wait
in where I'm out of my path three years
for you and the other thing is the other
thing is Jake and this is important Jake
arietta pitched with a lot of Jake
aretas in in Baltimore are you going to
be this guy spending a year around John
Lester and I asked Jake about this all
that stuff not on a stat sheet nobody's
finding it in war or anywhere else but
that matters oh yeah being around for
the first time in his career oh yeah you
know what I mean oh yeah all right bah
and I agree pictures are sensitive but I
bah Gregorian from the Kansas City Star
is next vah how are
you good good thanks for getting me in
um I wanted to direct this to Pedro if I
could just about Yordano Ventura sort of
in general but but Pedro also um he had
he had some struggles early in the
season and and some seem to be physical
some perhaps mental and I know you've
been close to him um I just wonder what
what you've seen and and how he's kind
of made it back and and What
observations you have about his
development well you you first of all
you have to understand that his maturity
is not there yet physically so taking
over the load of 20 and 220 Innings is
going to be a task for jordano Ventura
still composing himself and saving
energy to pitch longer than he that than
he's been pitching it's going to be a
task because jordano throws a 100 and he
wants to show that 100 in every pitch
and and and it's going to take him a
while to realize that when you save it
and you stay at 94 to 96 and then you
elevated it when you have to you go you
reach out for something else when you
when you need it for something extra
it's going to take him a little while
but just like aretta someday it will
click for him and his body will become
the body that's able to take on 200
Innings and 30 33 outings every year and
this kid is going to be scary because
his staff is unbelievable and he's
showing signs yes that he is capable of
doing anything now it's just a matter of
time and maturity and cancer city needs
to be patient with this kid that this is
a kid that's very emotional a kid that's
very energetic uh Sometimes He he'll
flare on you because he's got that
determination he wants to be like a like
a Pedro and and he wants to be
aggressive but he has to use this to
actually do those things well see I saw
that same transformation with with with
Johnny quto and and with the and vocus
yeah yeah but I mean all those you know
Dominican dudes to change up
but I'm just telling it's going to have
to command that third pitch that's right
but how much does that help I was just
about to ask you about that having quo
and VZ oh it's going to help two guys
who you manage and you know well I mean
how much does that help and guys that
can speak the language and Converse with
him and and and quto was going to help
uh Ventura even more than than VZ with
because VZ is is is is is it's a
firecracker right and Ventura needs to
kind of you know be be in in a small
circle like Philipe used to say you have
a small circle Pedro you have a small
circle Mo and Larry Walker and those
guys they got they got a big circle you
have to stay in a small circle and and
and Ventura is is at an age just like
hary where you can still hold the leash
and guide him and teach him little
things and I think quto is is is is
better suited to to teach Ventura more
than than than than vulas is because
vulas is a little firecracker vus a
keeping loose exactly exactly I think
qu quto quto will be the the one that
that's going to probably hitching po
those my those my two boys yeah but he's
going to be okay Ventura is going to be
okay Ventura needs to reach that
maturity that he needs physically and
mentally let's go to Mark Newman mlb.com
guys he's next hey
Mark hey guys um Dusty first for you so
many postseasons what is this like for
you in this kind of a role is in the
studio with these guys and then secondly
I'd just like to ask all of you if I
could for a prediction for tonight and
why well hey man I I you know I love
this time of the year and uh you know I
love being here with these you know with
these former players and uh uh you know
because I know they know what they're
talking about I know that they you know
are presenting the world with a
different outlook on things and uh uh
it's it's it's fun for me it's it's big
time fun for me I mean I'm I'm getting
nous now now CU he trying to shut up now
now you know if you pick against the
Cubs just to let you know our planning
we will be at the NLCS so if you pick
against the Cubs and they should get
there we will be in public in that area
no no no no hey I was there in
Chicago time but but I'm telling you
going to Pittsburgh is something
different too now now now if I was in if
if this game was in Chicago I would pick
Chicago but the but they're playing in
in Pittsburgh yeah you know I I think
the winner of this game is going to come
out of the National League feel that I I
just can't bet against AR right now I
just can't it just be foolish to be to
do that but the the best thing about
being on this show is nothing hurts
right and I get to talk about
baseball and and you look good well I
and you get and you get to have cigars
to be and I'm all right I'm all right
all right it says Gary Sheffield on the
inside of the shirt you can't see that
at home what about you he your
prediction well you know what right now
like I said earlier any bet against
aretta is is an uncomfortable bet you
you you're betting against I as much as
as I love gar Cole and I think they both
it might come to the to the buen it
might come to the battle of the buen so
I'm I'm extremely happy for either one
because I love G Cole I love the pist
Pirates I love what they're doing but
aretta is having
on a special year and it's a special
everything right this kid did not let up
at any point during the whole season I
don't think this is the moment where
he's going to let up I think those two
kids are going to go at it I think
they're gonna they're gonna uh end up
you know going to the bullpen and if it
goes to the bullpen Pates I think
Pirates win if if they both get there
now something happened because remember
we're dealing with two good athletes ARA
can hit right Ara can make you know the
difference in in the game and and and G
Cole is a good athlete as well but I
just I just believe aretta is having a
complete season all around and and and
every move seems to be going his way I I
I have to go Chicago Cubs if FS to the
starters and and and and you know if but
if FS to the bullpen I I think the
Pirates got them yeah you look at and
you and I both have the Cubs going
pretty deep into the playoffs I think
one thing we'll talk about this tonight
in our pre game show is the defense you
know in this game specifically how do
you get Alvarez's bat in where is he
going to play Outfield alignment for Joe
is quirky decisionmaking there with guys
who maybe aren't as an experienced in
the corners I think it' be interesting
to watch how that plays out those hey
those are tough Corners it's gonna be
tough and that crowd's GNA be there
bucktober although don't tell that to
Jake arietta who responded to a fan on
Twitter and said whatever makes you feel
better it's not going to matter I love
it that's what he said I love it to all
right let's send it out to mark hin from
the Tampa Bay Times hey Mark go
ahead hey guys uh Dusty if you could
answer first and then then Pedro and
chef but since you've been there how
hard is it to manage the Chicago Cubs
and what do you think of the job Joe
Madden has done well you know Joe
Madden's done an outstanding job and
they have a a lot of talent and they uh
you know they have a lot of talent from
uh you know from Latin America you know
they've drafted high for a few years and
uh and they've come on you know well I
was just thinking this morning when I
was there I'm I'm just hoping that you
know that holding Bryan back those you
know those 17 days or whatever is is not
going to come to haunt him because uh
you know imagine if he was there the
whole year they might have won the
division and so uh uh this is this is
going to be this is going to be pretty
tight today well I mean he's done a
wonderful job I mean he get he gets the
most out of his players and that's what
I I describe this as is this man can get
any player and he can it's almost like
he can look at you and say I'm going to
get the best out of you today every day
and he keeps these guys loose and let
them go out and play and have fun uh I I
I have to tip my heart to him and and
and and not not precisely by the way he
managed the players because the players
have been there now one move in the
infield hey surprised everybody right
Stanley Castro going the second and
getting the best out of him and not only
that improving at that position and
moving the young Short Stop to to to his
regular prion was a great move now
handling handling the bullpen and
handling the the rest of the starters
after aretta and Lester it was a big
task and that's where you really have to
tip your hat to to Madden and not only
that keeping everything without any
distractions right everything has been
smooth riding and and nobody has heard
anything about the any problem in the
clubhouse whatsoever so that's where I
Really T my had to mad but P they're not
supposed to hear about problems no but
no there are problems but they you know
you keep them in house exactly that's
why I'm saying exactly the own written
rules of M in the clubhouse how work
perfectly well I mean when you talk
about stuff leaking out of the clubhouse
when it don't leak out that's when all
players EMB bought into the manager
correct that's what that says you know
Mark knows this because he covered him
in Tampa Bay but in getting to know Joe
over the years I I would argue he's the
best Communicator I've met in my life
like even forget about of sport in terms
of just his innate ability to
communicate as a manager you know how
important that is and you're one of the
great communicators as well you know but
as players when you communicate the idea
to Presser at the beginning of the
Season we're going to win and then days
later Anthony Rizzo comes out and goes
tells the Press we're going to go win
the division you could tell the leaders
inside that room were already buying in
for younger teams and you guys played on
on these kind of teams I mean how
important is just that specific aspect
of our guy leading us believes we can
win so why not right well I'm going go
to Against The Grain on that because I
was under the impr I don't care who
managed
me I know but everybody like you I know
everybody I don't care who the manager
is job in the room but I know that
players you know need that and and then
we going to nurture you in that way but
just not me you know but I understand
what you're saying but like like if I
was ever played for Dusty B Baker I'll
be in his in his uh office every day
we'll just be talking I want him to make
me laugh loosen me up yeah so I mean
that's just that's just how I am the see
CH you know you know you know what we do
you know what we do when I'm pitching
and you take me out I'm Looking Over The
Bull oh who's Dy calling for oh my
God can I get one
more now when when when you're in the
Outfield sitting over there and you see
oh dust is going to take Pedro out now I
I wonder what what movie is it going to
who's coming from the bench to to to
double switch Yeah uh you managing too
yes you are so you want to feel
comfortable with your manager making
moves so you want to be part of I
managed when I was playing I used to
manage I used to manage from out if
you're in the game exactly but when it
when it came to what I had to do on the
field I'm going do my job and I'm going
let everybody else do that I just love
how you said pictures are sensitive and
pointed to Pedro and then said no see
those rules are for everyone
else not me Let's uh let's take some
questions from the fans Caleb Hofer on
Twitter we could all hit this one he
says guys did the winners of the wild
card games have added momentum Pedro we
saw this last year with the Royals how
much momentum do the Astros get for
example off of the win yesterday it
could be the biggest difference because
right now Kansas City is sitting waiting
for someone and I don't like that they
sleeping I don't like that I don't like
I don't like team sitting and and
waiting for the other teams that's hack
coming in and and and still feeling the
ball and feeling the bat from night
before I I I saw it in Detroit we saw it
in Colorado we've seen it so many teams
that that that when they sit down and
they wait for the other team the other
team's team rolls over uh the 04 Red Sox
in my team after we passed the Yankees
when we went over St Louis waiting for
Uso and you would have won 10 more after
that oh believe yeah and everybody is
about rest everybody how is about rest
you got to keep it rolling oh yeah you
have to keep it rolling and I and I
Kansas City showed it last year City
just got hot at the right moment and and
they just steamroll everybody now they
got to turn it back on now yeah it they
do and they'll get a chance in game one
coming up on Thursday you know this is a
good one from Sean Harold on Twitter
says do you think the current format of
the one game wild card is great drama
for baseball or should it be altered and
when you got a 97 to 98 win team I get
where we are but at the same time I like
what Clint Hurdle said which was
basically like look we're here someone's
going to win this is just the way it is
this is why it's important to win a
division now you guys all played in an
era where you had both where the
division mattered and then you played
when it didn't you play when a division
meant something Chef let me start with
you I mean how much of the aspect of
let's go win the division and that now
being important again does that mean
that this is working it make teams at
the beginning of the Season like small
Market teams Annie up I mean they can
sit back and say well we'll just try to
take a wild card but when you have to
Annie up to win your division you really
got to go out there and bring in players
I understand all the sides I won a
championship being a wild card team you
know and coming in you beat us yeah and
beat beat the Giants beat the Braves got
say don't give don't don't give don't
give him look come on bro he did what
what he was supposed to do about it I'm
sorry I'm a big home run you want the
Highlight I don't remember but the thing
is but the thing is it I understand
baseball trying to bring excitement to
the game it's more money for the game
it's keep excitement keep excitement but
when you got teams like the pirate in
the playoffs and the Cubs in the
playoffs that's good for baseball so why
not have a one game series and then let
best man win best team win best
organization and you know something with
you when the season starts you always
want to win the division right and then
and then say Okay since we can't win a
division now we'll take a wild card yes
you know the thing is you want to go to
the dance any kind of way that you can
but you would prefer to go as a Division
champion but they but one more thing
they they're not taking the easy route
by playing this one game no they're
going through it the hardest way correct
so now they're getting the Cardinals may
be sitting or these teams may be sitting
and waiting but the thing is they're
going about it the hardest way but you
know what let's simplify it m and and I
thought I just simplified it I'm not I'm
not no you know it it's so simple how do
you get to the World Series mhm one game
at a yeah there you go that's simp good
simpli you you yeah that that is really
simple you win one
game you're ahead that's right if you're
the Cubs or or or the the Pirates you
win one game and remember it's one game
at the time you never play those two
games to get to where you are it's one
game at the time continue to pile up win
look forward to the next day hey here we
are for the next day here we are
something I think we'll talk about guys
probably tonight that I think it's
important that we saw last year after
the game that we covered which was crazy
where they came down 7even to3 all that
we heard Alex Gordon and Eric cosmer who
played on our postgame show say we just
got all the experience we this this is
the experience we needed you're starting
with game seven nothing you do you're
now going back to game one so for a
Bryant for schwarber for Russell for
these kids guys I think it's different
now with the one game playoff than it
ever was because if they go ahead and
they go win this game oh yeah I'm not
saying the pressure is totally off I'm
going to game one I could lose the next
three I'm still around I'm telling you
game seven is it right game seven is it
I would have love to see for me
personally game six was you know was my
Nemesis I would have love to see Texas
just continue to play on yeah Texas just
keep going keep that momentum going keep
that momentum Houston could be scary now
going into Kansas City right hot from
the Yankees all they get is a is a a
little bit of a sleep between games and
and there they are a team young
energetic when you're on a road you
don't need sleep oh believe me hey the
Houston Astros beat the Yankees imagine
what's going through their head yeah not
good everybody look I guarantee you that
how many times do you think it was said
if George was still alive my on New York
Sports Talk Radio today could
come, um all right last one uh this is a
good one comes in from a fan uh in New
York he says what Young star from the
likes of Bryant kareah Seager and card
and I'll even add to his question de Gro
Harvey there are so many young kids here
which Young star do you think has the
biggest impact on a series this October
who wants to take that one Brian why
it's something about this kid that I
just love it's I like a lot of players
but I love this guy you could put him
anywhere on the field he would go over
there and he's still going to hit yes I
don't care where you put me I'm still
going to rake I mean this kid you know
when you heard of guys hit 10 12 home
runs in spring training then as soon as
the season started like where is I
remember where is this guy won't name
their names but you know the the you
know what happened to him in spring
training had to go down we know why but
to come back and not be bitter about it
and just go out and do his job and now
his team is in the playoff I love this
kid I I I'm G to go with the sleeper
nobody's thinking nobody's saying
anything everybody's just looking on I I
I think Noah cerar is it's one kid that
that could surprise the heck out of
everybody he throws near 100 yeah has
done it
quietly is building up his experience
has the demeanor to be out there uh he's
pitching you know critical game and he
he could become big because right now de
grum against kersha right you see that
PE battle right now having the the the
the extra arm just like the grum and not
well known not well mentioned uh could
surprise a lot of people I I like no
syar yeah saying I like Korea I I like
him a lot cuz this guy man he's hitting
third in the in his rookie year right
you know you know my rookie that ain't
easy that's not easy at all I mean I bet
at fifth by Hank Aon in my in my rookie
year and that's not an easy task and
this guy's hitting third but you know
something he got some people surrounding
him that that you know that aren't
afraid right you know when I when I look
over here at the right field I look at
the second baseman these guys come to
play and they come to play every day and
they got Gomez out there acting crazy
and loose and everything so so he's not
a late bloomer see Rusty I I just don't
think you if you if I have you in the
third spot it's for a reason right I
know I'm not letting you do damage on me
boy I'm keeping those two in front of
you out of the bases and then I'm
dealing with you out man yeah but how
you going to keep the the the the rest
of remember he can keep out two way off
the
base there miss they're a swing and Miss
team and and they either hit the Hummer
or or they swing and miss but altu swing
and miss too much well that's that's
your problem you have to keep altu away
from the Bas and then you pitch Korea
and you use his young experience to try
to fool him I yeah but he's a little man
uh Guerrero I mean he can hit the ball
anywhere high oh yeah yeah yeah
ball he hits the ball anywhere believe
me you can throtle his mind he's still
young enough where you can throttle his
mind and we saw it yesterday throttle
his mind I never heard that I don't want
any place that be thring my
mind all right so we we'll be back
tonight I would just throw in how about
Roberto Asuna 20-year-old closer for the
team everybody's picking to go win the
World Series he's gonna have to be one
of the best players on that team and
strowman's another kid with the Jays
despite the veterans so lot of young
kids and four young guys onet I picked
tonal first don't don't don't what you
mean you you you I picked him who are
they playing who are they plan who did
you have in plan well I had in plan
Miami that's correct thanks again for
joining us today tun the TBS tonight at
7:30 p.m. Eastern for more great
analysis and pregame coverage like and
pirates in the NL Wild Card that's how I
do you Dusty Baker games at 8:00 for
Pedro Dusty and Chef I'm the other guy
be good
people
[Music]